[Musique]
la sophrologie c'est vraiment une
thérapie un accompagnement pour que la
personne en fait plus gérer ses émotions
face à un entretien effectivement puisse
se préparer également bientôt
mentalement on repart de la respiration
contrôlée de la visualisation positive
et de la détente musculaire pourra se
concentrer sur sa respiration
on va par exemple inspiré du positif
pour les rejeter du négatif
[Musique]
le stress bien entendu le stress le
manque de confiance en soi
les problèmes de mémoire voilà d'un coup
on sait plus comment s'appelait l'on
sait plus on a dit voilà donc ça c'est
assez des problèmes récurrents
[Musique]
l'idéal c'est de venir à moi au moins
minimum avant voire un sophrologue
puisque c'est tout un processus est ce
qu'on appelle une préparation mentale
on va d'abord au départ enlever tout ce
qui est négatif ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure
donc enlever le stress enlever les
croyances négatif ensuite on va aller
poser du positif donc installer la
sérénité développer la confiance en soi
le lâcher prise la concentration plein
de choses pour enfin arriver à son
objectif c'est-à-dire arriver encore en
mode warriors donc sur sur l'entretien